I stayed awake for 24 hours in the
Gryffindor common room and I still can't
believe what I saw I started off my
morning with some breakfast this guy had
the same idea then a few other students
started showing up mostly reading and
studying but none of them not a single
one of them were as devoted as this
young man right here we'll call him
Joshua he and I are friends now Joshua
started off his morning frantically
riding with his quill and parchment
later I found him carrying this huge
stack of books not long after that he
had to reach for the snacks then it
started to get dark the other students
all eventually cleared out but not
Joshua frankly I started taking it as a
personal challenge to see which one of
us could stay awake for longer there
were moments it looked as if he was
staring right into my soul taunting me
to go to bed first this man started
reading a book in the middle of the
night not even batting an eye finally he
finishes his second book and I'm
thinking surely he has to be going to
bed at some point but no it's back to
the table and more writing for Joshua no
doubt pinning his own first novel after
reading two books back to back in the
middle of the night morning comes and
now we're past the 24 hour mark but that
is when Joshua starts to crack his head
starts to nod and finally Joshua falls
asleep